After a critically acclaimed and wildly successful
origin story, Wonder Woman is heading to 1984,
and when she gets there, she'll find a new
foe lying in wait.
Wonder Woman director Patty Jenkins has shared
the first official image of actress Kristen
Wiig in character on the set of Wonder Woman
1984, portraying the character Barbara Ann
Minerva, aka the villainous Cheetah.
While it appears to be a look at Minerva in
her normal "80s lady" form, it's still cool
to see the character come to life, for the
first time ever in a live action film.
Even if it DOES just look like a postcard
from a natural history museum, with Wiig standing
in a dark room, surrounded by exhibits.
Dabbling in big-screen supervillainy is a
new career move for Wiig, who made a name
for herself in comedy with Saturday Night
Live and her Golden Globe-nominated turn in
Bridesmaids.
She starred in the reboot of the Ghostbusters
franchise in 2016, but this is her first big
foray into the superhero genre.
Cheetah's cinematic backstory is still unclear,
and in the comics, it varies quite a bit.
In her first incarnation as Barbara Ann Minerva,
she's an ambitious archaeologist from a wealthy
family with a flexible moral compass.
She gains supernatural powers while seeking
immortality from an ancient god of plants,
or by cutting herself on an ancient dagger,
or she's cursed, depending on which series
you read.
In all of her incarnations, the transformation
leaves her in a tortured existence somewhere
between human and feline, her natural ambitions
supercharged by her immense new strength.
Between this inspired casting and the expected,
but still unexplained return of Steve Trevor,
Wonder Woman 1984 is shaping up to be among
the most interesting movies coming out of
Warner Bros. and DC in the near-future.
Jenkins confirmed on Twitter earlier this
month that, despite sacrificing himself for
the safety of the entire world, Chris Pine's
Trevor will be in the Wonder Woman sequel.
"Welcome to WONDER WOMAN 1984, Steve Trevor!"
Jenkins tweeted, along with a photo of Pine
looking totally '80s in era-appropriate clothes,
including what appears to be a Members Only
jacket.
You'll remember that Trevor appeared to have
died at the end of the first Wonder Woman
flick, which was set in 1917 during World
War I, but it looks like he somehow went on
to live for another 67 years, and didn't age
a single day.
Is this "Steve Trevor" a relative of the original
Steve Trevor?
Is there some sort of time travel in play?
Is a he just a stylish hallucination?
We'll have to wait and find out.
As a bonus treat, Wonder Woman herself, actress
Gal Gadot, also took to Twitter recently to
share a photo from the sequel.
In it, Diana is seen staring at a wall of
screens, most of which display period-appropriate
shapes, colors, and stock images, but one
shows actor Larry Hagman as J.R. Ewing on
the 1980s primetime soap opera Dallas.
From the original film's performance, we already
know the team behind this can make an excellent
superhero flick.
Wonder Woman broke a ton of records in the
summer of 2017, becoming the highest-grossing
DC Extended Universe film ever at the domestic
box office, the most commercially successful
superhero origin story movie in history, and
the top-earning live-action film directed
by a woman.
In total, the flick took home $821 million
worldwide and sits certified fresh with a
92 percent critical score and an 88 percent
audience rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Speaking with Entertainment Tonight, Jenkins
promised that the sequel will be a completely
fresh experience compared to its predecessor.
"It's not [Wonder Woman 2] to us.
It's an entirely new adventure."
Wonder Woman 1984 will be out in theaters
on November 1, 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!